[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARCUS EAST: Good
afternoon, everybody.
My name's Marcus East.
I have the best
job in the world,
in that I'm the Chief
Technology Officer for National
Geographic.
And what you just
saw on screen there
was just a slice of the National
Geographic image collection.
Now, we don't think of those
assets just as digital files.
Every single one of those
pictures that you saw
tells a story.
They're the stories
of adventurers who've
been around the world to
explore unknown places,
photographers who
are trying to capture
their knowledge of the
world, or researchers
who are trying to help
us better understand
the planet around us.
And we take our responsibility
at National Geographic
very seriously as the
custodians of those images
because those images
help to tell stories,
and those stories help to
improve people's knowledge
of the planet Earth, of
its people, its animals,
and its places.
And by doing so, we hope that
we can help people to care more
about the planet because if
they care more about the planet,
they're more likely
to protect the planet.
And so our team is incredibly
excited that not only do we
do things that are fantastic
from a technology perspective,
but we have an opportunity to
do things that are actually
meaningful to society.
So those beautiful images, many
of which that you recognized,
obviously have to be supported
by a great technology platform.
And at National
Geographic, we had what
we called a system called SPI.
And SPI was effectively the
home for these wonderful images.
It had roughly 17
terabytes of data,
housing two million
iconic images
that have really helped
over the last 130 years
to shape the narrative coming
out of National Geographic.
It probably won't
surprise you to hear
though that over the last
20 years, the team that's
responsible for running our
image collection had built--
they would describe it
as lovingly hand built--
an application in Java that
was over a period of 20 years
iterated upon.
We discovered there was not much
documentation unfortunately.
I'm sure that's a
situation that none of you
have ever experienced before.
It was hosted on premise.
And it was managed
by an operations team
without technical oversight.
And from my perspective,
when I first
joined National Geographic two
years ago, it was obvious to me
that it had what we describe
as a suboptimal information
security posture.
Now, that's a situation that was
clearly not acceptable to us.
And interestingly,
that system that
was housing the crown jewels
of National Geographic
found itself under
intense scrutiny.
And our VP of Information
Security came to me.
And she said, Marcus, I think
we have a bit of a problem.
This system is not
really fit for purpose.
In terms of the legacy
that we're protecting,
we need to do
something about this.
And we unfortunately
took the decision
to take that system offline.
And we worked with
the business team
to come up with a solution.
We helped them to
remediate the issues.
And after many,
many months of this,
we realized that this was
actually not going to work.
And we had to take
some drastic action.
Our CEO came to my
office and said, Marcus,
we need to do something here.
I'd like your team to take
responsibility for this.
And this was in
November of 2018.
Your team has to take
responsibility for this,
has to fix this application,
and get it back online.
And as he was leaving my office,
and he said, and by the way,
it must be up by January 2019.
So that's obviously
not something
that you ever want to hear.
We had a situation
where the crown
jewels of our organization were
in a system that needed help.
We had a very limited time
in which to do something.
And the thing that was driving
the need to do something
was what we call our
Storyteller's Summit, where
all of the famous photographers
that tell these National
Geographic stories
around the world
were coming to Washington
DC to National Geographic
headquarters in order to
celebrate photography.
And obviously,
that was not going
to be a great story if we
didn't have the archive up
and running.
The good news is
we like a challenge
in the Products and
Technology Function
at National Geographic.
In fact, two of my
colleagues here,
Melissa Wiley, our VP
of Digital Products,
and Mike Debnam, our
VP of engineering,
huddled with me in my office.
And we said, what are we
going to do here in order
to resolve this problem?
We didn't have much time.
We were familiar with the cloud.
We had spent a lot of time
working on a migration
to the cloud.
But we realized that this
needed to be something
special, something more.
We decided to reach out to
our friends at Google Cloud.
And the reason that
we did that was
not just because we felt that
they had incredible technology
and a great solution to the
problems that we were facing,
but we felt there was
an alignment of values.
In our conversations
with them, we
understood that they cared
as much about the environment
as we do.
Things like
sustainability were things
that they talked about when
proposing to us using Google
Cloud as a possible platform.
And we then set about,
just before Thanksgiving,
the process of putting this
incredibly valuable archive
back online.
Google worked very closely
with us, both from a technology
perspective, but also from
a professional services
perspective.
We introduced a third
party called Globant.
And, in fact, that was
Google's suggestion.
We already had an existing
relationship with Globant,
so we were very happy
to work with them.
And you can imagine
what the next eight
weeks was like with a team of
people working around the clock
to take this legacy application,
to move it into Google Cloud,
to protect it.
In this case, we
used technologies
from both [? Oracle ?]
and Akamai
to protect access
to that application.
And we were able to get
it up and running in time
for the Storyteller Summit.
Now that's not something
that we would necessarily
want to do again.
I would not encourage anyone in
the room who's a technologist
to sign up for an
eight week mission
critical deployment to
the cloud, but we did it.
And I would say that
it was incredibly
rewarding to work
with both Google Cloud
and Globant to get that done.
You can't have a
CTO on the stage
without an architectural
diagram, of course.
I don't have time
to go into this.
But what I would say is that
one of the beauties for us
in working with Google
Cloud was the flexibility
that they brought.
I think when Tarik made
his opening comments,
he really brought that
home with this focus
on solving business problems.
The fact that we had
other systems that
were connected to SPI
and other systems that
were dependent on it
wasn't an inhibitor
to working with Google Cloud
to get this application up
and running.
So what about the future?
We've obviously been able
to take this application
and get it into
Google Cloud, make
it available to
our photographers
and our internal
stakeholders again.
And that's been wonderful.
In fact, I received hugs and
kisses from our photographers
as a result of us
having done that.
But there is an
interesting future.
One of the reasons that we
chose to work with Google Cloud
was our excitement about tools
such as AutoML and the Cloud
Vision API that would allow us
to do things such as enriching
the metadata that goes
with these wonderful images
that we have in our
image collection.
And we believe that we can
utilize the power of GCP
and some of the native
capabilities in Google Cloud
to build even more compelling
stories and even more
compelling experiences
in the future.
But the most important
thing is that the legacy
of our photographers
is now safe.
And these are not
just the legacies
of these individual
photographers.
In some respects, they are
part of the legacy of humanity.
These are stories
that need to be told
that people need to understand.
And I'm delighted to say that
working with Google Cloud,
we were able to secure
the image collection not
just for ourselves, but for
many, many generations to come.
[MUSIC PLAYING]